started that game five nothing Bruins and an
olon got two goals late but obviously it was
long over by that time as Greenway the former
wild the click in the former Bruin stop rebound
y nobody got him and huk made the save good
chance there for Tyson J that they wanted to
the game the third line for the Sabers gets on
to the ice and they go to work and it's just
from low to high shot and rebound we talk about
the fact that their offense hasn't been what it
was last year brillan took the pass beon RS it
there's Lowry tries to stuff it in he almost did
played it off the goenda it goes right to appeton
with a weak shot you have to ensure that it's not
a one and none all the time look at that good
job grinding it's two versus three they win
the battle look at Lowry picks the stick up and
where does he go instinctually right to the net
darene receivers being patient here in the game's
first Power Play middle skitter off his skate and
the M the c a littleit Morgan Baron trying to get
in between the two Sabers Morgan Baron still with
it backhander stopped and held by Eric Tom and
inspired Rush from Morgan Baron do a good job
defensively and block a shot you've got a good
chance to catch them with numbers that's exactly
what happens here with Baron and thees you're
in the right place defensively you catch them
with four guys below you and now you've got a
in tyght two-on-one second unit out there for
Winnipeg nikov takes it over the line drops it
off needer ryer good pass back the Fe the P with
a shot stopped by C can't f it that backhander he
got that one and a good looking attack from the
Jets as they came quickly over the blue line
he watch the way he's moving his feet and he
pulls two guys to him in the corner and you're
looking into high ice and a good job stepping
into that slot area this weak side D watch Neil
p as he sees oh there's the lane so you have to
put yourself in a position to get a pass theof
doesn't Oh What A Memory I ran into him today
after the skate he was he was all smiles he said I
feel pretty good so he was ready to go and I said
it must be something to see those pucks come
in that fast he just shook his hand here's a
chance for Olson and he was denied in tight
Victor olon with a great opportunity to open
the scoring under a minute to go brenon Dylan
is on it for Winnipeg that's a smart pass and
a breakaway pass and it's Kyle Conor in on Al lone
Conor shry oh and he just missed it on the second
cck and maybe you cheat a little bit because
you realize okay we've got clear possession
and he's heading northward early and this is
just a breakdown I mentioned the Sabers wow
po of chopped that by Stanley game
number three of the season for him this
here now floated ahead nikov is there three
Jeter on the Move here's perit with a shot
he [Applause] scores what a release Cole Peretti
his sixth and it's one- nothing a great headband
pass from Pon and an even better pickup from
Nestico who literally picked it up with his hand
to settle things down and just leaves the puck
right into a lane for Peretti who extends his
goal streak now to five games in his point streak
to eight sharp shooter number 91 Tim gon has at 18
points in the season exactly three times he had a
19point season as well mentioned earlier long time
saber Eric Johnson ahead looking for Garson hel
out play it then he wants to get back in position
made a pretty good save there he gets it to the
Conor with AO turning shley stick break and he
is frustrated he throws that down who knows what
would have happened with that shot had the stick
stayed intact the Jets are on the move again
knock down by Lowry he'll Tee It Up to the net
SC again the low e Rider Appleton line strikes and
it's two nothing WI a shley and his stick explodes
but they reload they change lines and how about
that drive to the net and you will get rewarded
stick on the ice and Mason Appleton blowing snow
as the puck two goals early in the second frame
and it's from simple plays to the net two goals
in 2 minutes 21 seconds turning is Skinner good
po rebound they score Alex tuck picked up a loose
buck in the slot he be teluk and it's two to one
WI a pick he had three goals in his last two games
before he was out with injury and just a churning
play shoot it to the net a rebound and you have
to tie up body and stick well you get the body but
not the stick and it's the rebound so the power
play is over one shot right over the line neita
Ryder snaps one off the Stick of power and high
and off the Glass Long Shot the SC and it's Bron
Dylan elers with the shot that one off the Sabers
defenseman in front and it is aers and it's 3-1
in this building and then now he tops it off with
a goal of himself and he just gets this one out
what a weird play as he's holding the offensive
line and he just whips it to the net and this is
a seeing eye shot that pass eventually collected
by Ryan Johnson over the line leaves it for PETA
looking back door it does get through to a turning
Skinner Loos it from and a big save by look as he
stoned Peta who had a great chance there he
had to be careful didn't want to move it back
to the line because middle step was waiting for
the buck Benson head mans it and here comes PKA
with a step on Dello right in stopped by H with
the blocker save Mark that one down a big one as
heluk need the Stop and just watch the feet that
quiet feet from Conor heluk that he's so good at
he doesn't move well if eers can find his way
and he looks like he's going to do that that
would really out the Jets we know that no shots
on that power play here's J hit the go post and
his rebound was stopped by helar you can hear
that one all the way in Steinbach backing up D
there's a shot and that is knocked Away by helar
really is a blow to that what a breakout he's had
the last couple of years now cage Thompson came
in that Ryan O'Reilly deal here's back from St
Louis and it looked one-sided but in the end maybe
the Savers win that Breakaway pass here's PKA stop
by H and he scores in the rebound good stick toed
this by JJ PKA is seventh of the season and it's
3 to2 been more stretch passes in and behind the
defense and that's not just for Buffalo it's for
both teams remember Kyle Connor's opportunity
and it's been going back and forth and both
teams are really good off the rush and this is
just anticipation from a young player in petka
12 goals last year in his rookie season and he
extends it now to seven already in this young
season High follows from Eden New York about a
half an hour south of Buffalo as do much the sa
he said sort of we went to games very rarely his
parents wer they they named him after mcil that
shot and sto by heluk and the rebound lifted over
the net throwing pucks and bodies all over heluk
to the back door what a brilliant look off from
darene and that is unbelievable stretching out
to keep that out of the net now KBS will gra
that delene drives the net he's got the puck
alone stopped by hel B coming up knocked to the
top of the net out of the air by Dalene battle
first position and then the Jets get caught putt
watching and they're flat footed to their own Blue
Line delene comes in with things have got pretty
tight in this period skated to safety by Josh
morrisy over the line he leaves it here's Adam
Lowry right in can't get a quality shot loose
puck in front and cover is down still alive and
Upp for grabs olon kind of F off elers out front
of the goal just out of the reach of nesop eers
up and on it his pass nesop good startop with
Cy nesop again he couldn't shoot boy look at
that pressure all four guys are attacking at
the same time for the Sabers Shipley's almost
able to break the pressure but the Sabers have
been good down a mat shley takes it away he's
got Kyle Conor Mark shley drags it shoots stop
by covery and no rebound what a big save with
a minute and a half to go using the two-on one
as a decard Koy look at the way it starts though
he's on the defensive side good defensive stick
look at the way he looks off C drags and boy 6
seconds to go middle snap for power time running
out to even for the drive and that's just
miss the it and the Jets heading [Applause]
on